موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله افادت وكاله رويترز بان
بريطانيا تدرس تزويدها اوكرانيا بدبابات
لاول مره من اجل مواجهه القوات الروسيه
ونقلت الوكاله عن تقريرا المناقشات تجاريه
منذ اسابيع بشان تسليمي 10 دبابات
بريطانيه من طرازي تشالنجر اثنان لوكانيا
على تغيير اي شيء بشكل جذري وفي موضوع اخر
قال الكريم لان انه لا صحه للمزاعم عن
موجه جديده من التعبئه الجزئيه في روسيا
قالت القوات الروسيه وانها تحرز تقدم على
محور في مقاطعه من جهته قبل الجيش
الاوكرانيين الجيش الروسيه قصف مدينه
سوليدار
22 هجوما في محاوله لاقتحام المدينه
اعتمد مجلس الامن الدولي قرارا يمدد العمل
باليه ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه عبر
الحدود الى سوريا لمده سته اشهر ويسمح
القرار بادخال المساعدات الانسانيه عبر
معبر باب الهوى على الحدود مع تركيا دون
اذن من النظام السوري من جهتها قالت
منظمته منسقوا استجابه سوريا انا اعداد
المحتاجين الى مساعدات انسانيه في سوريا
تجاوزت 15 مليون نسمه وهو الرقم الاعلى
منذ 12 عاما
تعهد الرئيس البرازيلي لولا دا سيلفا
بملاحقه من سماهم مموليا تحركات
الانقلابيه وكشف ان اجهزه الامن اعتقلت
الفا وخمس مئه شخص على ذمه التحقيق في
اقتحامته مراكز السلطه في البرازيليه وشدد
على ان الديمقراطيه لن تفلت مجددا من ايدي
شعب البرازيل
اعرب الرئيس الامريكي
البرازيلي لولا دا سيلفا في اتصال هاتفي
عن دعم الولايات المتحده ثابته
للديمقراطيه في البرازيل واللي نتيجه هي
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي فاز بها الاولى
واستنكرار رئيسنا اعمال العنف والهجوم على
المؤسسات الديمقراطيه البرازيليه
قال البيت الابيض انه وزاره العدل تراجع
وثائقي يحتمل ان تكون سريه تم العثور
عليها في مكتب كان يتبع للرئيس بايدن في
واشنطن قبل تسلوي مهامه رئيسا للبلاد
واوضح ريتشارد سوبر المستشار الخاص لبيضن
ان الوثائق تحمل وسم السريه ووقعت بين
ايدي محامي الرئيس الحالي عند اخلاء مكتبه
بعد انتهاء ولايته النائبه للرئيس اوباما
عام 2017
ونقلت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه عن رئيس
مجلس النواب كيفما كارتيت وصفه العثور على
وثائق سريه بمكتب كان تابعا لجودا قبل
تواليها الرئاسه بانه امر مقلق جدا واتهم
الديمقراطيين بالمبالغه في رد فعلهم اساء
ما فعله الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب مسبقا
اشكركم على متابعه المجازر لما كنت
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]